[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresser au premier
ministre voilà dix ims voilà 18 mois que
le premier ministre
seul sans concertation décidé d'imposer
le 80 km heure sur les routes
départementales
oui 50 % des accidents mortels ont lieu
sur les belles routes départementales
secondaire mais les causes ne se trouve
pas dans la limitation à 90 ou à 80
elles sont aussi et surtout ailleurs les
grands excès de vitesse l'alcool les
stupéfiants les imprudences et
contrairement aux prévisions d'experts
malheureusement le 80 km heure n'a pas
permis de sauver plus de vies cette
mesure est un échec
vous l'avez tellement bien compris que
vous renvoyez maintenant au président
département la responsabilité d'une
décision non concertée qu'ils n'ont
jamais souhaité il nous avait pourtant
mis en garde ceux qui veulent passer aux
90 km heure sont freinés par des
conditions drastiques élaboré par des
instruisent ou experts du comité
national de sécurité routière qui à mon
sens ne doivent jamais été passé
périphérique parisien trouvait dans nos
campagnes
une portion de route de 10 km cinq
carrefours sans habitation sans arrêt de
transport sans engin agricole
c'est vraiment se moquer des élus c'est
tout faire pour les culpabiliser 43
départements réfléchissent et souhaite
passer à 4 90 5 départements souhaitent
rester à 80 mais 53 départements
s'inquiète hésite
le résultat se traduira par des
limitations de vitesse différentes d'un
département à l'autre
ce ne sera pas un gage de lisibilité et
de sécurité pour les automobilistes
alors monsieur le premier ministre
faites cesser cette hypocrisie faites
cesser cette guéguerre des experts gifle
contre chiffre fait cesser ces querelles
stériles qui fracturent nos territoires
vous seul pouvez en décider rené sur
votre décret du 15 juin 2010 8 revenait
aux 90 km/heure et les élus prendront
sauront prendre leurs responsabilités